for a high level guest a fist bump hello
mike pompeo was in tibilisi to emphasize
continued american support for georgia
at a time of
regional instability and a raging
pandemic
we want to do everything we can to
support your democratic process the
building out of the institutions
one of which i'm honored to be had today
to build up these institutions in ways
that are important with free and fair
elections and all of the things that
come with robust debate
and democracy but george's opposition
says free and fair elections failed to
happen
this october this downtown protest
was organized to attract the u.s top
diplomats attention
to a domestic political crisis
they accuse the government of
manipulating the results of a
parliamentary vote
and backsliding on democracy election
definitely was rigged in georgia
and this is ridiculous and the georgia
is
usli and we don't want to back to ussr
the opposition also want the government
to take a stronger stand
against vladimir putin russia has
military bases in georgia's two
breakaway territories
south ossetia and abrasia and
last week russia deployed two thousand
peacekeepers
to the nagorno-karabakh conflict zone in
neighboring azerbaijan while the u.s and
georgia already cooperate militarily
ahead of pompeo's visit former georgian
ministers and ambassadors
called on the u.s to provide a permanent
military presence in their country
we don't know what would be the final
outcome of this uh
so-called ceasefire or conflict but it
really uh
sharpened the colors of the contours of
this idea as a
necessary immediate means to maintain
uh georgia and our region or a
right track of peace and security rather
than being a tool of russian
geopolitical manipulations
it was a short stop on a busy itinerary
for mike
pompeo but his visit has huge
significance but the only democracy in a
region
where the balance of power of late has
shifted away from the united states
robin forrester walker al jazeera to
bilisi